hello everyone it's a good thing it's
Sunday because a game like this should
not be viewed during the week for a game
like this you want to be as arrested as
possible it's a game from round 10 of
the 2013 candidates tournament and as
we've seen in the previous video were
Gelfand had that beautiful victory
against LaVon Aragon these are the
standings at around 9:00 so Carson has 6
points he has sole first place and Boris
Gelfand is all the way up to 4 and a
half points so he has a very nice chance
here if he beats Magnus Carlsen he can
join well someone to join the leaders
and gain five and a half points and
before we see the actual game we do have
a couple of photos from this round here
as usual you have a nice photo of a
bunch of photographers taking a photo of
Magnus Carlsen quite a quite a popular
guy even before he became world champion
here we have a nice close-up of Magnus
cos and it's it's like he's saying could
you please take photos of someone else
please then we have a nice photo of Gail
fun he just arrived at the board with a
glass of water in one hand and a
handshake in the other and here we have
a photo of the two of them they just
started playing golf and of course
played c5 the Sicilian to cross in c4
and he's trying to achieve iContact -
maybe - maybe scare off his younger
opponent and in the back you can see
Peter Dodgers doing the one-handed photo
very nice so let's see this game like we
said get from the doing nice in this
tournament already two wins and facing
Magnus Carlsen but with the black pieces
what will he do so II for Carlson opens
up the game
we have c5 the Sicilian and yet again I
forgot to lower the volume so we don't
hear double moves sorry about that I
will try to remember that for the next
video Knight to f3 Knight to c6 and now
once again cross and goes for Bishop to
b5 the Rosso lemo attack or sometimes
called the measurement Dean of Rosa limo
attack we have E six castles Knight the
G to e7 and rook to e1 a6 Bishop to f1
d5 and E capture Sun d5 and
goes in the night captures on d5 you
don't want to capture with E then this
rook is a spinning this 97 and it will
be very hard for black to develop here
after d4 captures captures captures
captures like black will really have a
lot of problems how to how to develop
his King side pieces so after a capture
Sun d5 Knight captures on d5 and d4
Knight to f6 by Boris Bishop to e3
captures captures and we have Bishop to
d7 Carson goes for c4 Knight captures on
d4 Bishop captures on d4 and the bishop
to c6 so already engagement has a very
nice position for his Bishop here the
dark square Bishop is also ready to come
into the game all is well
Knight to c3 and Bishop to e7 cross in
place a3 preparing before maybe at some
point so get fun stops that he plays a5
Queen to d3 and we have castles now cost
and connected rooks so he can develop
her them rook a to d1
and Queen to c7 Queen 37 it's it's not
all that easy to find an active move
here for black you still have to develop
your rooks
maybe maybe this rook can at some point
be developed via a6 it's hard to tell
but you definitely want to connect rooks
as well Queen to c7 does make sense as
crossings idea will be something like
Queen to g3 maybe Queen to h3 then bring
this bishop from f1 back into the game
and and create some sort of an attack
against against the black king so Quinta
C 7 makes sense if Queen g3 then get
funded will definitely trade Queens
first the bush of to e5 attacking the
Queen and here Queen to b6 was played we
have Queen to g3 now by Carlsen and of
course you have to ask yourselves can
Queen capture pawn and b2 so for those
of you who are maybe new to chess maybe
we want to pause the video here and try
to figure out if this is possible I will
give it a couple of seconds as usual
it's not a very hard tactic but a very
nice sound a tactic so for those of you
who figure out the correct answer
congratulations you are an excellent a
trap avoider
because if Queen captures then of course
you see that knife to d5 wins the game
immediately this opens up the attack
from your Bishop to the Queen and after
you move the Queen then simply Knight
captures on f6 well we knew the game
this comes with two check you can't
capture here because if you capture then
the Queen and a3 is undefended
so you'd have to move your king and then
after a night to h5 well not immediately
of course but let's say after look to d3
attacking blacks Queen after black moves
the Queen now Knight to h5 will we need
a game easily as there is no defense
against Queen captures on g7 so after
this Queen to G to remove by Carson rook
F to D 8 we have rook captures and e8
rook captures and e8 and rook to d1
again attacking the elephants Queen and
this is a this is really the moment
where you really have to I mean not you
get font should have really took have
taken a lot of time here and figure out
what to do Geffen went for one plan and
the engine suggests a different plan but
for a human when you play a practical
game you don't really understand why an
engine is suggesting this the engine
suggests Queen back to f8 which which in
the long run will make sense but you
will only realize that probably at the
time gave and realized it as well
so given play the Queen to b6 he wants
to infiltrate White's position with the
Queen
we have Bishop to d4 Carlsen attacks the
Queen Queen to be 2a Queen to b3 of
course capturing the point is isn't
possible to do to the same idea
rook the d3 and now Queen to c2 we have
B for a capture some V for a capture
some before and now Knight to h5
attacking the Queen and here Carlson
plays Queen to e5 so he attacks the
night on h5 what do you do here here get
offense plan was actually to play rook
to e1 but rook to a one doesn't work due
to a very nice tactic rook to e1 the
idea being that you want to take control
of the back rank going to see one it
will be very hard to stop Queen captures
on f1
but night the d1 actually is a beautiful
move this opens up an attack from from
the bishop to the rook on 8:1 so after
rook captures rook captures Queen
captures you will have Queen to be a
check and after Bishop f8 then you have
Bishop to c5 and it will be very hard
for for blacks to do anything here Queen
captures on f8 is coming you have to
create some room for the king after
Queen captures King to h7 now of course
you would like to capture on f7 but this
isn't really possible because black
would gain the upper hand
we had Bishop to b4 and then Bishop to
d3 with a similar idea white just did
but after f3 preventing Bishop to b4
it's very hard for black to find the
move f5 as f7 was attacked
now b5 kicking the bishop back and after
Bishop to d7 Queen to b8 not allowing
this knight to come into the game and it
will be and also attacking the b7 pawn
it will be very hard for black to play
this so Gelfand decides not to go for
this idea rook to e1 but still you have
to figure out what to do you even if you
could you can't really move the knight
because of Queen captures on g7 but ok
as the position is as it is there's
really no way no square for you to move
the knight even Knight to f6 doesn't
really work for you because of b5 you
have to push back the bishop because the
bishop is attacking efore and have to
remove the bishop then 9 3 4 is coming
and now or even better even better than
Knight to e4 Knight to d5 now Knight
captures on d5 is impossible because of
checkmate on g7 and even if you capture
with the pawn then Queen captures here
will be will be a very deadly idea so
after this Bishop to d8 move which is
after Bishop to 8 nights the d5 the only
idea here would be Bishop to d8 now
guarding c7 and also not allowing knight
Knight captures on e7
but here here comes nice to see 7 and
after captures captures it will be very
hard for black to play this you don't
want to allow Bishop captures on f6
followed by root 2 G 3 so after this is
prevented
Queen captures and these two connected
passports will win you the game
eventually the rook is under attack so
you cannot capture on c4 and after you
prevent this then white will simply
start pushing his pawns and win the game
so after this Queen to e5 move we've
seen that rook t1 which was originally
played by gelfand and Knight to f6 don't
work
Caitlyn decided to play Bishop to f6 it
seems like it loses a piece but not
really cross and did play Queen captures
on h5 Bishop captures on d4 was played
Rock captures and now Queen to c3 as the
rook is no longer guarding at the knight
on c3 and here it seems like gallant
solved all of his problems he has a
beautiful bishop on c6 cross and has a
very passive Bishop on f1 although the
bishop is very useful guarding the g2
one and also route to a one is coming
you know it's very hard to stop this so
in a in a critical position like this
it's very important to find the best
move so I try to pause the video here
and try to find the best move in the
position to move Carlsen plate so I will
give it a couple of seconds if you
decide you want to try and figure out
what the best move here is so for those
of you who found that congratulations
you are you you really do know how to
how to use your Sundays and for those of
you just won't enjoy the show here
crossing plate
Queen to a5 Queen to a5 of course with
the idea the Queen is now attacking the
rook if you capture the Queen of course
route to d8 will be checkmate after
Bishop blocks so you don't have to do
something best way to retreat the rook
is rook to f8 because on effect the King
will also be guarding the rock you don't
want to play something silly and then
allow rook to d8 Queen to b6 now
guarding both both the b-pawn and the
rook on d4 now we have E 5 and now rook
to d1 g6
guys one has to create some space for
the King and here we have b5 simply
grabbing more space Bishop to b4 and now
comes Queen to f6
we have h5 creating more room for the
king and now comes h4 a great one that
wants to activate that that
but it's very hard to do it we have
Bishop to f5 and now look to d5 and now
you see that it there really is no way
for you to protect the e5 pawn here
Queen to c1 was played by Geffen Queen
to c1 with ideas of of course if rook
captures which would be a terrible
blunder then Bishop to d3 would easily
we need the game but of course cousin
did play that cousin played Queen
captures an in five but this was going
to find that gay fans idea he decided to
give up one points to be able to
activate his pieces so Bishop to e6
attacking the rook rook the d4 you have
to play this as both the Queen and the
bishop are attacking the c4 pawn rook to
e8 now preparing rook to a1 and Queen to
e2 and here King to h7 is played the
problem with the obvious rook to a-1
which seems like a great idea
I do hope all of you can see it but
maybe it's not so obvious
I feel free again sorry to pause the
video here I mean it's the game contains
a lot of nice nice ideas why is the rook
to e1 a terrible move try to find the
winning idea here for white so once
again this is I believe the third puzzle
in this video if you solved it
congratulations this is now now a
complete hat-trick rook to d8 of course
wins the game after came to h7 Queen to
e5 is coming and there is no defense
against a rock to rock to h8 checkmate
even if black captures the bishop of
course you have to see that this you
have to give up the bishop after King
moves Queen to g1 check King moves rook
to a3 check after f3 there's really
nothing to do here for black there are
no more checks and it's impossible to
prevent rook to h8 you do have to
consider rook captures if maybe black
has some tricks here but even after King
captures Queen f1 check after King g3
there are no more surprises and rook to
h8 is inevitable so after Queen to e2
first King to h7 not allowing rook to
the 8th to come with the check so now
rock day one definitely is a threat rook
to d1 by Carlsen not allowing it Queen
to c3 and now Queen to e4
we have looked to a one route capture
screen captures and now c5 so after
drugs have been exchanged now Carlson
will push his advantage of the extra
pawn and see c6 is coming so Queen to c3
now we have Queen captures on b7 and now
Queen to e1 if you play Queen captures
on c5 then b6 is coming queen is coming
to c7 and then this pawn will win the
game eventually but after going to be
seven we have Queen to e1 bag elephant
Caitlyn is now planning Bishop to c4 but
here comes the shocker b6 get on the
display Bishop to c4 and now comes Queen
to f3 a very important move now if
Bishop captures on f1 across and had in
mind Queen captures on f7 would check
King to h8 and now Queen to f4 and it's
very interesting that both of these
phones are on dark squares the queen is
also on f4 on dark square and there are
no good discoveries to be made after
worship day 6 check let's say King will
simply move and after Queen moves let's
say Queen to e8 queen is coming to c7
and now this dark square diagonal is
covered there are no more checks for
black and simply c6 and b7 will we knew
the game so after this Queen to f3
girlfriend played Queen captures on f1
with check we have King to h2 and here
we are Queen to b1 b 7 and after b7 I
believe after b7 it was that Gelfand
resigned the game yeah after b7 I will
have to check what out I believe after
b7 he he resigned the game why did he
resign well there's really nothing to do
here Carlson will simply push the points
the victory but after let's say Queen to
b5 and c6 Queen to d5 no he didn't
resign yeah I remember now yeah sorry
about that
after b7 Queen to b5 was played Carson
played c6 and now Bishop to g5 e I
remember sorry and Geffen displayed this
and only after Queen to g3
did Gelfand resign in the game so yeah
of course he resigned that because if
Bishop captures then
simply you bring the pond to be eight
and you promote the Queen and really any
other move you play results results the
same simply this and White has two
queens and it's all over
so yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it after Queen to g3 Geffen
resigned the game and we do have a nice
photo of gala fund after he resigned I
don't believe I don't know if this is
the exact moment he resigned but I don't
think anything Pleasant happened at this
moment when this photo was taken so yeah
you know around 10 was a very eventful
round there were a lot of decisive
results so we will show I believe three
games for round ten two more games
tomorrow so you know stay tuned as usual
you can check to my previous videos here
a thing called for watching and I will
see you soon with two more videos from
round ten of the 2013 candidates
tournament thank you all and I'll see
you soon